so can we just start because we're
celebrating your film tonight and in the
legacy of this but we're also
celebrating the lyrics of stephen
sondheim and can we just talk about you
know what this titan has brought
well you know it's really amazing when
you've got such a gift that stephen you
know had
from from
childhood i mean you have to understand
that oscar hammerstein took stephen
sondheim under his wing and advised him
to do west side story when stephen
wanted to write his own music and do his
own words and oscar said no no you're
working with leonard bernstein jerome
roberts and arthur lawrence you will do
these words so this all came from
oscar hammerstein advising stephen to
make one of the best choices of his
entire career
which basically brought us to where
we are today in both celebrating and
mourning stephen absolutely how much
convincing did it take for you to get
rita to come on as an executive producer
and then make a cameo in the film well i
think the first step first things first
i asked rita if she'd come on to play
valentina because she was the best human
being on the planet to play this role
and in the process of getting to know
rita i realized what a value she would
be
to the community as as we have cast all
latinx actors to portray the girls and
the boys of the sharks
and uh and i suggested i said would you
ever consider
you know being not just a performer in
front of the camera but working with all
of us behind the scenes as our executive
producer and she absolutely said she
would thank goodness can i ask you about
rachel because you when you have to cast
maria
like
that's a daunting task and then you find
rachel who's relatively unknown she was
not known she was a junior in high
school she was 17 years old when i found
her she sent in a singing audition which
sydney told the casting director had
compiled there were 35 000
uh self tapes
that were sent into cindy tolen's office
rachel
on the second day of casting i saw
rachel
and i cast her a year later
foolishly i thought if anybody can sing
that well and act that well on my first
day of casting imagine who i'm going to
find on the 60th day of casting nobody
ever reached her high bar
that gave me chills and there she is
your star yes there she is
yes we're talking about you yes
you take over for me yes
good no easy task so i can leave the set
and you can direct the scene
or you can direct this very very very
tough act i would never try to take a
direct directing from you so you tell me
what to do you tell rachel not what to
do and we will do it okay what you can
do is just uh play it by ear and i'm
going to step uh stage right
okay
and we'll clap thank you so much
[Music]